وبعد اكثر من عام على المفاوضات سارت
بريطانيا على سكه اتمام الاتفاق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لمحاوله الحد من مشكلات
سياسيه وتجاريه في ايرلندا الشماليه ويبدو
انها نجحت المشكلات هذه مشاهدينا تسبب بها
اتفاق خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهو المبرم في عام 2020 المفاوضات شهدت
التعثر مرارا بسبب الخلاف بين لندن
وبروكسيل حول تعديل جزء من الاتفاق وفي
اطار وقعت بريطانيا اتفاقا مع بروكسل
معروف باسم بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه
لتفادي نقاط التفتيش المثيره للاحتقان
السياسيه على امتداد الحدود البريه مع
ايرلندا العضو بالاتحاد الاوروبي ماذا
يعني ذلك بموجب البروتوكول نشات قيود تمنع
نقل بعض البضائع من بريطانيا لانه ابقى
ايرلندا الشماليه في السوق الاوروبيه
الموحده فاليوم وبعد لقاء رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه اكد الرئيس الو ان الاتفاق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحمي سياده ايرلندا
الشماليه ويمنع وضع حدود بين ايرلندا
الشماليه وجمهوريه ايرلندا
طاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي اشاره سونات
الى ان بريطانيا فتحت صفحه جديده في
العلاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وانه سيتم
تطبيق قانون الاتحاد الاوروبي في ايرلندا
الشماليه لتفادي وضع حدود في الجزيره
[موسيقى]
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي يحمي سياده ايرلندا
الشماليه ويمنع وضع حدود بين ايرلندا
الشماليه وجمهوريه ايرلندا بما يؤول الى
ازاله كل عقبات نقل البضائع التجاريه بين
ايرلندا الشماليه وجمهوريه ايرلندا كما
نود الاشاره الى انه سيتم تطبيق قانون
الاتحاد الاوروبي في ايرلندا الشماليه
لتفادي وضع حدود في الجزيره وازاله اي
حدود بحريه في البحر الايرلندي بشان
العلاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي بريطانيا
فتحت صفحه جديده في العلاقات معه